[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
ihnen allen einen schönen samstagabend
katja stresow mit der täglichen dosis
sport wie heute und die dosis ist heute
groß und vielfältig guten abend die
wichtigsten nachrichten haben wir in den
nächsten 20 minuten für sie sortiert und
das gehört unter anderem dazu
ein toter viele verletzte und enorme
schäden unwetter wüteten in einigen
regionen deutschlands
tornados ziehen durch
nordrhein-westfalen
schwere angriffe im osten nach der
einnahme von mario pohl verstärkt
russland die offensive im don bass
und vorfreude aufs pokalfinale freiburg
und leipzig hoffen auf den ersten titel
ihrer vereinsgeschichte
[Musik]
ungewöhnlich hohe temperaturen und dazu
enorme feuchtigkeit die dann auf fast 20
grad kältere luftmassen trafen dass die
zutaten für die unwetter die gestern in
weiten teilen deutschlands tobten
besonders getroffen hat es nordrhein
westfalen mindestens drei tornados gab
es dort laut deutschem wetterdienst in
mit maßen einem ortsteil von höchster in
paderborn und in lippstadt die polizei
geht von schäden in millionenhöhe aus
mindestens 43 menschen wurden verletzt
13 davon schwer über das ausnahme
unwetter dort färber und ariane gügel
der tag danach in paderborn bäume
umgestürzt dächer abgedeckt und menschen
noch immer unter schock
seine küchentür einfach eingedrückt er
konnte sich gerade noch auf dem boden
werfen
die sind abgebrochen wie streichhölzer
also eine urgewalt war das wirklich
300 meter breit 5 kilometer lang 150
stundenkilometer windgeschwindigkeit so
verwüstet der tornado die innenstadt von
paderborn erste zäune dachziegel alles
fliegt durch die luft
heute die bilanz des bürgermeisters
hunderte einsatzkräfte
43 verletzte darunter eine frau die noch
immer um ihr leben kämpft paderborn ist
entsetzt paderborn ist schockiert und
paderborn ist mehr als tief betroffen
die kirchturmspitze einfach weggerissen
auch durch lippstadt fegte ein tornado
eine urgewalt und fassbar und neu in der
dimension
einer halben stunde war der spuk vorbei
und sämtliche bäume gerade in die wege
bereichen waren auf die straße gestürzt
und es war unglaublich es war wirklich
eine zerstörung wir noch nie gesehen
haben noch ist das ausmaß dieser
zerstörung gar nicht zu beziffern
nordrhein-westfalens landesregierung
macht sich am nachmittag ein erstes bild
vor ort
dieses unglück hier zeigt auch einmal
mehr dass wir uns auf solche extreme
wetterereignisse immer häufiger werden
einrichten müssen dass wir darauf
vorbereitet sein müssen uns zeigt
natürlich auch die bedeutung des
klimaschutzes drei tornados wüteten
gestern durch ostwestfalen und
überraschten trotz eindringlicher
warnungen viele menschen
nun bleiben die trümmer es wird lange
dauern bis diese schäden behoben sind
ariane gödel ist für uns in paderborn
ariane wir haben die menschen gerade
noch gehört die sind noch richtig
angefasst wie ist die situation einen
tag nach dem mega unwetter dort in der
region
ja einen tag danach ist der tag des
aufräumens und viele haben die wir
getroffen haben haben wohl auch heute
erst so richtig realisiert welcher
naturgewalt sie gestern tatsächlich
ausgesetzt waren sie haben erzählt dass
sie auch einen tag danach viel anders
gesagt immer noch zittern sie haben uns
berichtet wie schnell das der tornado
kam wie er gewütet hat um die stelle
auch wieder von dannen gezogen ist und
viele sagen auch dass sie natürlich auch
irgendwie glück im unglück hatten weil
es immerhin hier keine gegeben hat hier
in paderborn
hier in paderborn sieht man regelrecht
wieder welche schneisen der tornado
region hat hier in dieser straße ist
fast jedes haus betroffen die dächer die
ziegel sind weg von den dächern die
fensterscheiben sind eingedrückt in
einigen häusern sind ganze fenster aus
den rahmen gedrückt worden nach innen
gedrückt worden der putz fällt von den
wänden
also ist nichts mehr so wie es mal war
und wenige straßen weiter wir haben die
menschen ganz normal ihrem
samstagnachmittag im garten verbracht
also man sieht auch einmal hier wie er
so ein tornado wirklich begrenzt auf
wenige straßenzüge wütet und ein mann
hat uns zum beispiel gezeigt wie im
vierten stock seines mietshauses in der
ast eines baumes in die hauswand gebohrt
hallt durch den beton also daran sieht
man mit welcher kraft diese naturgewalt
gewütet hat hinter mir ist gerade eine
familie dabei auszuziehen das chaos ist
kommt das dach ist komplett weggefegt
die wohnung ist unbewohnbar also fiel
die wir gesprochen haben sind wirklich
heute noch oder heute erst recht
geschockt dass sie so etwas überhaupt
erleben mussten dankeschön nach
paderborn ariane gödel und auch in
anderen regionen haben die unwetter
große schäden angerichtet
im westerwald starb ein mann nach einem
stromschlag in einem überschwemmten
keller nahe dem großen brombachsee
stützte eine hütte ein 14 menschen die
dort schutz gesucht hatten wurden
verletzt ein kind musste mit dem
hubschrauber ins krankenhaus gebracht
werden insgesamt rückte die feuerwehr in
franken mehr als 400 mal aus in der
oberlausitz sorgten in der nacht umher
fliegende gegenstände für mehrere
einsätze in schmöckwitz stürzte an rund
200 jahre alter baum auf ein wohnhaus
verletzt wurde glücklicherweise niemand
nach dem fall von mario pohl toben
weiter heftige kämpfe im osten der
ukraine schwere gefechte werden aus den
regionen lohans und dann jetzt gemeldet
die ukraine fürchten dass es russland
durch den weiteren vormarsch gelingen
könnte eine landbrücke hin zur krim zu
errichten wir sprechen gleich live mit
unserem reporter der in der strategisch
sehr wichtigen hafenstadt odessa ist
zuvor der bericht von volker dutschek
ukrainische aufklärungs trupps unterwegs
nach der frontlinien der region luhansk
hier im östlichsten zipfel der ukraine
hat die russische armee in den
vergangenen wochen viele panzer verloren
und viele soldaten doch nach dem fall
von mario wolf in moskau die offensive
weiter vorantreiben
der russische beschuss hat in den
vergangenen tagen stark zugenommen die
ukrainische armee kontrolliert nur noch
zwei städte in der region luhansk
dissidenz und sie wäre donezk und tag
für tag fliehen mehr einwohner
wie dimitrow moser der 32 jährige will
weg aus musik tanz seine frau starb nach
einem mörserangriff mit den zwillingen
steht ja am busbahnhof
ich denke nur daran wie ich meine
töchter hier raus bringen kann und wir
unser leben wieder auf kurs bringen wenn
die bezirke donezk und lohans unter
kontrolle sind ist eines der
wesentlichen ziele des kreml erreicht
der durchgehende landkorridor bis hin
zur besetzten krim nach der kapitulation
der ukrainischen soldaten aus dem
stahlwerk hat mario pohl nicht mehr die
strahlkraft als symbol für hoffnung und
widerstand gegen den russischen adresse
die stadt ist fast komplett zerstört
ein bruchteil der ehemals 430.000
einwohner ist geblieben nur wenige haben
noch eine intakte wohnung oder ein dach
über dem kopf
in unserem haus leben nur noch vier
parteien
hier drüben in dem haus und da geht noch
mal drei familien kharkiv die
millionenstadt im norden des landes nach
wie vor umkämpft die bevölkerung hat
teile der stadt zurückerobert aber auch
das fordert viele opfer wie viele hier
und im ganzen land gestorben sind wird
man sicher erst nach dem krieg erfahren
moskau hat nach eigenen angaben die
stadt malin nordwestlich von kiew
angegriffen vom meer aus sei eine große
ladung im munition und ausrüstung aus
den usa und europa zerstört worden
unser kollege johannes hano ist mit dem
auto von kiew nach odessa gereist hatte
johannes wie ist es in der region oder
sa und womit rechnet man
also muss sagen die situation hier in
odessa ist eine sehr merkwürdige
atmosphäre insgesamt einerseits sind die
straßencafés geöffnet gehen die leute
wieder in bars und kneipen das leben
kehrt zurück auf der anderen seite ist
das militär extrem angespannt und nervös
vor der stadt schwer bewaffnete
checkpoints rund um die stadt ein
massiver verteidigungsring und in der
stadt überall beton und sand barrikaden
man rechnet wohl mit häuser und
straßenkampf hier nichts von alldem
dürfen wir zeigen hat angst dass der
russischen zielerfassung dienen könnte
was fehlt sind die touristen die
normalerweise die stadt hier bevölkerung
um diese jahreszeit strandurlauber aber
daraus wird nichts weil es kein benzin
gibt um hierher zu kommen wir selbst
mussten uns unsere kanister aus kiew
mitbringen um auch wieder zurückzukommen
dann gibt es das problem strandurlaub es
gibt kein strand und auch bei der strand
komplett vermietet ist also es lohnt
sich gar nicht erst hierher zu kommen
denn die ukrainische truppen rechnen mit
einer landungsoperation der russen die
steht zwar nicht unmittelbar bevor sagt
man uns aber wenn der landkorridor auf
die krim in russischer hand fest in
russischer hand ist und möglicherweise
in der ost ukraine erfolge erzielt
werden und rechnet man damit dass die
russischen truppen hier auch wohl besser
marschieren könnten um die ukraine vom
meer abzuschneiden dankeschön nach oder
st johannis hannover das live ja gerade
in kriegszeiten versucht man bündnisse
zu stärken us-präsident beiden sucht
nicht nur die nähe zu nato und eu
partnern sondern auch zu strategischen
verbündeten wie südkorea und china etwas
entgegenzusetzen
darum ist joe biden zum neuen
präsidenten nach seoul gereist wie man
chinas wachsenden einfluss auf halten
und mit dem gefährlichen nachbarn
nordkorea umgehen will dazu ulf röller
jedes bild jeder auftritt soll eine
botschaft senden
us-präsident beiden gedenkt der
gefallenen soldaten des koreakrieges
damals kämpften die usa mit den
südkoreanischen truppen gegen china ist
auch heute der große gegenspieler in der
region um das macht einzudämmen sucht
der neue südkoreanische präsident die
nähe zu den usa amerika sieht sich gerne
in der rolle als schutzmacht
[Musik]
unsere beziehungen sind entscheidend für
frieden und wohlstand in der region
der ist bedroht das sind sich beide
sicher sie wollen ihre militärübungen
deshalb ausweiten sg um die verteidigung
der freiheit sagen sie
wir erleben eine weltgeschichtliche
zeitenwende es gibt einen wettbewerb der
systeme zwischen demokratie und
autokratie
einer war nicht im raum und doch
anwesend nordkoreas diktator kim jong un
der korona ausbruch schwächt das land
das wird aber kaum nicht daran hindern
weiter raketen zu testen und sein
atomwaffenprogramm auszubauen das ist
die größte gefahr für die region beide
regierungschefs sind trotzdem zum
gespräch mit nordkorea bereit
die tür für verhandlungen steht offen
wer nordkorea wirklich sein atomprogramm
aufgeben will
nicht nur in europa auch am anderen ende
der welt in asien rückt amerika mit
seinen bündnispartnern enger zusammen
in den usa spaltet das thema
schwangerschafts abbrüche das land
seitdem durchgesickert ist dass das
oberste gericht das recht auf abtreibung
kippen möchte bringen immer mehr
republikanisch regierte bundesstaaten
strengere gesetze auf den weg und das
ist auch die linie der katholischen
kirche die gerade in den usa große
schlagzeilen produziert warum zeigt
benjamin daniel
sie ist eine der ranghöchsten
politikerinnen amerikas und jetzt darf
sie in ihrer heimat diözese keine
kommunion
das hat san franciscos erzbischof
angeordnet der grund nancy pelosi setzte
sich für abtreibungs rechte ein es ist
ein weiteres beispiel dafür wie
aufgeheizt das thema in den usa ist erst
am donnerstag ging eine schockwelle
durchs land als in oklahoma ein gesetz
verabschiedet wurde dass fast alle
abtreibungen unter strafe stellt
das leben beginnt mit der empfängnis und
wir werden es beschützen andere staaten
können es anders handhaben aber wir
stehen für das leben
der gouverneur wird das gesetz wohl bald
unterzeichnen habe den moment der
befruchtung dürfte dann nur noch
abgetrieben werden wenn das leben der
mutter in gefahr ist oder es sich um
inzest oder eine vergewaltigung handelt
und auch nur dann wenn sie der polizei
angezeigt wurde eine solche regelung
wäre mit dem bundesweiten recht auf
abtreibung nicht vereinbar dennoch hat
der supreme court eben dieses recht
nicht aufgehoben deshalb wollen
demokraten dagegen vorgehen
es wäre ein direkter angriff auf das
fundamentale recht der selbstbestimmung
zu leben und zu lieben ohne einmischung
der regierung
rund 60 prozent der amerikanerinnen und
amerikaner sind für eine liberale
regelung des abtreibungsrechts und
trotzdem versucht eine konservative
minderheit auf allen ebenen und mit
aller macht ihren willen gegen den
willen der mehrheit durchzusetzen das
thema reißt die ohnehin schon tiefen
gräben in der gesellschaft weiter auf im
kongress war ja findet also wieder genau
die polarisierung stadt die sich die
populisten wünschen
australien hat gewählt und nach den
bisherigen auszählungen steht das land
vor einem regierungswechsel
nach fast zehn jahren kehren die
sozialdemokraten unter anthony albern
asse an die macht zurück mit seinem
zentralen thema dem kampf gegen den
klimawandel konnte der 59-jährige vor
allem bei jüngeren wählern punkten der
konservative amtsinhaber scott morrison
hat seine niederlage bereits
eingestanden aber da mögen die klima
versprechen noch so groß sein australien
wird wohl auch unter einer neuen
regierung weltweit größter exporteur von
kohle bleiben so viel geld zu viele
arbeitsplätze hängen an dem klima
schädling der durch den ukraine krieg
gefragter ist denn je normen odenthal
vollgas das ist das tempo das sie hier
an den tag legen sie können die kohle
gar nicht schnell genug aus der erde
holen australien schwarzer schatz wird
gebraucht von china bis indien und
findet gerade immer neue abnehmer was
der industrie volle kassen beschert und
eine portion genugtuung
ich würde meinen dass viele staaten mit
blick auf die jüngsten ereignisse in
europa die ausrichtung ihrer
energiepolitik überprüfen müssen und das
dürfte dann ganz sicher auch den
weiteren einsatz von kohle energie
einschließen
wer energie aus russland nicht will
braucht andere lieferanten australiens
kohleindustrie ist ein krisengewinner so
herrscht in der dorfkneipe statt
zukunftsangst nun zuversicht die kohle
ist nicht am ende durch die ukraine
krise ist die nachfrage riesig das wird
ja noch nicht vorbei sein unsere kohle
wird einfach gebraucht und wir haben
hier die beste qualität und es hängt so
viel dran so viele jobs sind minen bei
zulieferern die ganze kette wenn du die
kohle auf geben würdest was dann
die kohle stand lange am pranger
schuldig gesprochen für den klimawandel
dessen folgen australien so heftig spürt
überschwemmungen buschbrände extreme
dürre doch der ausstieg scheint und
wieder ferner denn je der weltmarktpreis
für kohle kennt derzeit nur eine
richtung steil nach oben und australien
ist der weltgrößte exporteur wenn das
geschäft brummt haben's bedenkenträger
klimaschützer natürlich schwer denn es
lässt sich im moment einfach zu viel
kohle machen mit der kohle
unser kollege norman und teil aus
australien jetzt so katja stresow und da
heißt es berlin berlin wir fahren nach
berlin ja ich heute nicht mehr heute hat
aber in der tat haben das sicher einige
gesungen heute am dfb-pokalfinale sc
freiburg gegen rb leipzig im berliner
olympiastadion und alle erwarten ein
intensives spiel vor ausverkaufter
kulisse eins steht schon fest einer von
beiden gewinnt den ersten großen titel
der vereinsgeschichte
sie haben spezialisten für wichtige tore
in ihren reihen ob forsberg bei leipzig
oder peterson bei freiburg das
verspricht ein haar umkämpftes finale zu
werden der spiele dafür um irgendwann
mal so an bord in die höhe zu halten
da haben wir jahrelang dafür gearbeitet
um einmal so eine chance zu bekommen
diese weg was wir gegangen sind bisher
wir wollen irgendwann das grünen und und
irgendwann alt einen titel zu holen oft
nur durch fouls zu bremsen ist leipzigs
christoph kongo gerade erst zum spieler
der saison gekürt zwei finales haben die
sachsen in den letzten drei jahren
verloren
eine erneute pleite treffe sie härter
als ihren gegner und wenn man nick
wilder und runter wer also gewinnt den
ersten titel beide vereine werden von
großen fan gruppen unterstützt das
berliner olympiastadion wird diesmal
wieder restlos gefüllt sein
ausverkauft war gestern abend auch das
fritz walter stadion in kaiserslautern
allerdings sahen die fans im ersten
relegationsspiel um den platz in der
zweiten liga zwischen dem fc dynamo
dresden keine tore der fck in roth hatte
möglichkeiten beugt sehenswert aber
erfolglos in der 27 minute
dresdens beste chance dann in der 56
minute reaktionsschnell gegen da ferner
die entscheidung dann am dienstag in
dresden
bei der eishockey wm in finnland steht
deutschland vorzeitig im viertelfinale
war gruppenkonkurrent dänemark heute
frankreich schlug ist dem team von tony
wieder holm der platz unter den top acht
nicht mehr zu nehmen und gute
nachrichten auch vom tennis den
angelique kerber hat beim tennisturnier
in straßburg ihren ersten titel auf sand
seit sechs jahren gewonnen im finale
besiegte sie die slowenen kaya huber
nach mehr als drei stunden und drei hart
umkämpften sätzen zur formel 1 beim
qualifying zum großen preis von spanien
hat es mich schumacher als zehnter
erstmals in die top ten geschafft die
pole position holte schale claire im
ferrari
charles' claire in jedem training der
schnellste so auch im qualifying zum
vierten mal pro position in dieser
saison auch weil verstappen red bull
streik in der letzten qualifying runde
keine chance mehr zu kontern für den
weltmeister der noch platz zwei weg
schumacher zehnter zum ersten mal
erreichte den letzten
qualifying-abschnitt weil konkurrent
norris wegen eines regelverstoßes eine
bessere zeit gestrichen wird sie war es
denn vettel trotz neu gestalteten autos
enttäuschend auf rang 16
besser dankeschön katja und vom rennen
in barcelona jetzt noch zu einer royalen
berg und talfahrt die dänische königin
margrethe die zweite unterwegs in einer
achterbahn gibt's nicht alle tage heute
aber im freizeitpark tivoli in
kopenhagen und die monarchien schienen
tatsächlich spaß zu haben ist aber auch
kein wunder schließlich gibt es auch was
zu feiern nämlich ihr 50 thronjubiläum
königin in achterbahn auch was schönes
bis auf einzelne mögliche schauer morgen
ein freundlicher sonne wolken mix
genauer erklärt es gleich katja
horneffer gegen 22.45 ordnet christian
sievers nochmal die nachrichtenlage im
heute journal ein dann von uns für sie
noch einen schönen und entspannten
samstagabend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend gestern sind ja heftige
gewitter uns hinweggezogen und es gab
auch tornados die bilder aus paderborn
haben sie sicher bereits gesehen das
dazugehörige unwetter tief ende ist
inzwischen nach osten abgezogen und hat
platz gemacht für hoch das hat zwar
einen imposanten namen macht aber schon
am montag platz für das nächste gewitter
tief im jahr heute nacht gibt es noch
etwas regen an der ostsee im süden ist
es dagegen auch klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 5 grad
morgen gibt sehr freundliches wetter
sonne und wolken wechseln sich ab
allenfalls an der ostseeküste oder auch
am oberrhein kann es mal für einen
kleinen regenschauer erreichen die
dampfzüge luft ist aus deutschland weg
geräumt so wie es morgen angenehme
höchstwerte zwischen 20 und 26 grad an
den küsten ist es sogar richtig frisch
bei 16 bis 18 grad und dann kommt der
montag und damit von südwest neue
gewitter die auch wieder
unwetterpotenzial haben im nordosten
bleibt es dagegen sehr freundlich der
dienstag wird eher durchwachsen der
mittwoch deutlich kühler bei 14 bis 23
grad schönes wochenende